all right well let's go to 908 call her
from 908 can you hear me what's your
name where you calling from yeah David
yeah I'm from New Jersey great what's on
your mind I just wanted to call and get
your honest assessment on whether or not
you think any of this justice Democrat
candidate will win in 2018 Isaiah I
really do you have a son son pure fun um
no I have you on my headset okay all
right cuz we got a crazy echo listen I I
have no idea who the Justice Democrats
candidates are is there one you think is
going to win I think the one with the
best chance um honestly is collagen
firms and money against Romancing just
because joe Manchin is so badly hated um
yeah I think she could probably win but
I see that they had a big spike after
the election and now like they're kind
of they're not getting as much buzz let
me ask you this conceptually Isaiah do
you think it's a better investment of
funds and I'm not asking rhetorically
I'm genuinely curious what you think is
it better to invest money given that
there's a limited amount of money to
spend in West Virginia by Democrats is
it better to invest money primary
concern of Democrat or trying to win
multiple House seats held by Republicans
what do you think it would be better for
Democrats if they could do i yeah I
concerning my thing with that they're
not running against any Republicans
right now and I do you think it would be
better to run against the Republican
yeah I mean again I don't know who the
Justice Democrats candidates are but as
a general thing I think if there's an
opportunity to knock out a Republican I
would prioritize that over primary a
Democrat that's just me though you know
it could certainly be possible to that
the West Virginia primary challenger the
Democrat defeats joe Manchin but then
because you've pulled yourself so far to
the left
yeah and you lose the Republican and a
recognize it is a conservative State all
right Isaiah sorry I can't say more
about it but but I do appreciate the
call and it's very very interesting and
we will be following
all of the primaries and elections